what is depression
and
what are the types of depression what
kind of depression
have you
seen and experienced and researched and
how can people overcome it how can
humans overcome it and deal with it live
within overcome it
so this is my clinical uh specialty i
see patients in my outpatient clinical
work with
treatment resistant depression so very
hard to treat severe illness where
medications haven't been been working i
also see patients with autism spectrum
disorders these are my two
clinical
focal areas
but then i do emergency room work uh
as well
but
the depression
why do i focus on that it's so uh
one feels tantalizingly close to helping
these
uh people who are suffering
so deeply that's and that's why i
focused on it is
these are people who
there may not even be anything
situational that's that's difficult or
challenging in their life you can have
people who
seem to have have everything that you
would want every objective measure of
the life is fine and yet they can be
uh
just uh hit with this
unstoppable
hopelessness and inability to see into
the future
a
discounting of the value of their own
action anything they can imagine
themselves doing seems worthless or
they
are unable to enjoy things we call this
anhedonia there's no reward no pleasure
not in food social interaction movies
books
anything that they would enjoy
positivity gone
they can have a profound
negative internal state psychic pain
and these things can seem and
in the severe cases are inescapable
so what is going on why why is this
state part of
the human existence it's
got a strong
biological genetic link we know that
it's been linked to certain genes
certain regions of the chromosome
and twin studies there's a clear genetic
link
it doesn't explain everything but it's a
big part of it genetics are a strong
contributor
and although you can have depression
without anything terrible going on in
your life the symptoms can be made worse
by stressors by trauma
and
but at a very deep level
uh there's nothing we can measure in a
person objectively so we don't have
there's not a known
chemical not a known structure
that's different not a known brain
activity pattern that we can pick up
with eeg
a lot of people are exploring this but
right now we have no objective measures
all we do is talk to people and we
elicit these symptoms
we explore them
distinguish them from other possible
causes
and then what do we do
well we have a range of treatments we
have medications that uh can help people
do help people but not everybody um and
if they don't work then we can go to
brain stimulation methods we can do
things even like electro-convulsive
therapy which is uh
very effective but it's that's a sort of
the final thing we go to in the end
and
so we have treatments they they work uh
for some people they don't do everything
we'd like but here's the problem is at a
very deep level
we don't understand really what's going
on in the brain we don't have a physical
interpretation of the problem
we have all these symptoms
but we can't yet point to a set of cells
or a set of circuits or an activity
pattern that is causing major depression
this disease state per se in human
beings
why do you think you can't yet from an
optogenetics perspective is it because
there's so many possible causes is it so
much so many things involved
so i think the answer is there are many
things involved and all these different
symptoms that i've mentioned
those we can study and those we can fix
the individual symptoms and we can do
this in animals to be clear so in a
mouse for example we can instantaneously
and precisely
turn up or down
the motivation of an animal to overcome
a challenge we can turn up or down its
ability
to to to be motivated by or we think
experience reward from from uh
situations or actions
we can increase its apparent energy
level it's it's uh it's it's its drive
uh to meet challenges
uh we can turn up or down social
interaction uh
all these individual features of
depression individual symptoms we now
can point to exact projections and cells
that are causal in mediating these but
we don't know is why
all these different symptoms show up
together
in major depression in the human disease
syndrome and that's that's the mystery
it's sort of
in other fields of medicine you know
someone with congestive heart failure
who comes into the clinic they have very
different symptoms they have shortness
of breath
and they have swollen feet okay couldn't
be two
more different uh across the body uh
sets of symptoms
neither one obviously related to the
heart but they're both happening because
the heart is not working as a pump okay
and and now
thankfully in cardiology
we understand these disparate symptoms
that seem totally unrelated
can be completely understood because
there's an altered pump action of the
heart that's that's what we are hoping
for in in psychiatry and in in the study
of depression or any disease
these different symptoms the inability
to enjoy things
the hopelessness
uh what's the what's the unifying
unifying i mean is there is there some
truth to that the tolstoy quote that all
happy families are alike and each
unhappy family is unhappy in its own way
so basically
i mean this is the human condition
and and it basically that might you know
the physicists long define the theory of
everything
it isn't understanding depression
essentially
require you to really have the big
theory of everything for the human mind
i think we
it would certainly be nice to have a
theory of everything don't get me wrong
i don't think we need
it would be nice
it's also a good question if it's
possible yeah yeah well that that i i
have uh some thoughts on too but but to
your to this specific question um i
don't think we need a theory of
everything i think there will be
unifying principles principles we can
get to but even shy of that if we can we
can treat symptoms and that's a big step
and as you say different different
unhappy families are different different
unhappy people are different
if we have somebody who comes to the
clinic and i see someone with a profound
anhedonia as one of their main symptoms
inability to enjoy things and if i know
based on optogenetics work and animal
work that a particular medication
can treat anhedonia even if it doesn't
fix major depression in everybody if i
treat that one symptom in that one
person
that's a good thing
and and so i we don't need
the theory of everything and we don't
even need the unifying principle to help
people with insights that come from
optogenetics
so how much does talking help
for diagnosis and for treatment
would you say for depression
it's a big part of what we do every good
psychiatrist is
should be pretty adept in
these verbal communications and talk
therapy as part of what they do
i give medications i deliver brain
stimulation treatments but
a big big part of everything i do with
every patient is talk therapy because it
works so well together with
these other modalities even alone it can
help people with moderate or
or mild depression by itself
people with severe depression people
with other
psychiatric illnesses that are are
severe
you don't want to do talk therapy alone
it's not going to do it but it still is
crucial to do together with the others
and it's it's it's critical because it's
part of how you re shape cognitions you
know
complex activity patterns and and you
won't get to that with a medication or
brain stimulation treatment
you